I know the time now is 6pm you guys are
wait at you now can you spare a few more
minutes can you maximize your time to
ask the panel any question this is not
to actually ask a question is to pick a
fight with Stevens so that I can break
his leg and he can't go to salsa I just
I'm just jealous about his height youth
and all the thing oh you're killing me
man never mind so I heard something and
that's like something that analytics or
data or quantitative information is not
important feeling is my question is
where is the contradiction right saying
that feeling can make your social
presence great it's like even if I have
a bad product and if I'd really don't
believe in my product I can go in social
media and create a great magic it's not
possible that's given that you have a
great product to start with you are
passionate about your business and you
are really a true believer of what
you're doing not too just to make money
right that's given but then you have to
take the qualitative stiff and
quantitative all the information and
analysis to go to do the right thing
isn't it true for me it's the difference
between thinking with your head or
knocking with your heart right and your
brain is limited into a world that
exists what that exists right now where
your heart can create any world that you
want okay let me tell you through a
story when I was growing up in high
school and never thought it was going to
be an entrepreneur I thought I was gonna
be a VP at a bank I look at my high
school yearbook that's what it says VP
at a bank okay I didn't have family of
entrepreneurs they didn't know what was
going to do when I got to university I
hooked up with a software company I
became an owner and in my final year I
got job opportunities with McKinsey
Consulting and Merrill Lynch which only
a few years fire would have been a dream
scenario I couldn't imagine working for
a better company
they were offering me 80 to a hundred
thousand dollar starting salary the flew
me out to New York put me up in the
Waldorf Astoria to try to get me to join
the company and I'm balancing two things
eighty to a hundred thousand dollars a
year three hundred dollars a month with
my company what does the brain say to do
what is a quantitative data I say to do
it's easy go for the job that's where
the money is but it didn't feel right so
you have to listen to your heart that's
my view you have to listen to your heart
you have to be passionate about it my
friends thought I was crazy they weren't
getting those job opportunities they
said Evan what do you look what is this
company and years later like 10 years
later my friends now coming back to me
and they're saying Evan I took that job
in investment banking and I hate my life
I now I want to start my own business
how do i do it and I'm so glad that I
didn't make that decision the smart
thing to do right the quantitative
logical money making thing to do to go
get the job i had no logical reason no
logical reason to stick with this three
hundred dollar-a-month company but i
didn't well as an answer your question
no actually not sorry so what I meant
that obviously you have to be passionate
to start with right so you have to be
like I took up entrepreneurial life of
my own so that's the given right then
after that when you're taking decision
day by day every time if your heart says
do that and go this side and every time
the heart says go to the left if you go
that side and you have no actual
evidence to support your decision you'll
be running around in everywhere not
reaching anywhere right so you have no
no disagree okay disagree quite often
the analytical decision
is the wrong way to go because you're
restricting yourself of a world that
currently exists or you can create any
reality you want yeah you have to
believe in what you're doing that's the
whole point of my first presentation you
pick your one word right if you guys
don't believe in what you're doing there
is no passion so yeah you have to pick
your one word you have to start a career
or business around that but I believe
your decisions should be based on what
gets you excited you're creating a
social media campaign I would challenge
you guys that why put that video up that
believe video 150,000 views in one month
not made on any quantitative decisions I
made it because I wanted to make it it
needed to be made and I'm proud of what
we made and I would challenge you guys
with no advertising to see what videos
you've made based on quantitative
decisions that gone that well what you
just stated as a proof of success you
said this is watched this many times you
just give a quantitative information to
support the theory that quantitative
disinformation doesn't matter I don't
say it doesn't matter now I mean that's
not it it doesn't matter but it's not
the main reason no this is a big
difference it's not the main reason for
doing anything right you can still look
at it Steve Jobs didn't say I'm going to
lose all my money I'm gonna just throw
it all in R&D he still had to make money
but it was never the main reason for
doing anything okay I think we think
they saw fine
we have time for one or two more
questions does anybody want to go next